[Musique]
salut à tous et bienvenue pour une
nouvelle vidéo sur le sacrifice de dames
alors déjà combien de points vaut une
dame une dame ça vaut 9 points bien sûr
la dame c'est la pièce la plus forte du
jeu un niveau 9 points les tours ça veut
ça vaut 5 points cavaliers
jusque là tout va bien
maintenant beaucoup de gens d'entre vous
pensent que la dame c'est sacré c'est la
pièce qu'il faut absolument pas perdre
même pas échanger des fois et ben
écoutez bien la dame très souvent et ben
on l'a sous-estime mais très souvent
aussi on l'a surestime des fois on peut
très bien échanger une dame pour
plusieurs pièces et voir un peu ce qui
se passe par exemple là j'aurai une
partie une partie c'est une ligne
théorique qui existe dans la Silent time
Manor regardez bien E4 c'est 5 cavalier
3 E6 donc T4 puis on prend cavalier
prank elle va laisser 6 donc ça c'est
une time en off ca va laisser 3 Tam CZ
c'est la théorie fou au 3 à 6 qui
empêche cavalier Bessin et ben non car
elle est pas simple quand même alors
cette ligne était beaucoup jouée à
l'époque maintenant beaucoup moins parce
qu'on a découvert que finalement cette
Lina
elle est plutôt bien pour les Noirs vous
allez voir
car elle est promet 5 pièces de plus
déjà pour les noirs
dans B8 fou V6 qui va venir faire une
belle fourchette en C7
fou échec en B4 je mets le pion devant
je mets le four à 5 pour échanger du
coup les fous vu que j'ai une pièce
d'avance je vais essayer d'empêcher un
peu tout ça et là le coup des blancs
c'est cavaler cette échec donc la
fourchette a lieu d'un procès 7 meilleur
coup de la position on va sacrifier la
dame pour le matériel non regardez bien
les Blancs ont une dame et un pion pour
les trois pièces donc là au niveau du
matériel une dame et un pion neuf plus
un 10 et moi j'ai trois pièces d'accord
ce qui fait 3 + 3 + 3 ça fait 9 mais ici
trois pièces en milieu de jeu peut
souvent surclasser une dame parce que
j'ai trois pièces j'ai trois petits
soldats qui sont forts qui vont lutter
contre une seule grosse pièce et la dame
blanche et ben on ne peut pas être de
partout à la fois donc cette position
est bien la réputé pour être compliqué
mais les Noirs généralement ont aucun
problème ici pour jouer pour l'avantage
dans cette position même si j'ai une
dame de moins donc voyez bien vraiment
tous ces échanges comme ça de dames
comptez les points plutôt que la dame
donc la dame vraiment c'est la meilleure
pièce mais des fois si on l'a plus c'est
pas si grave que ça alors maintenant
d'autres exemples ici vous avez un match
qui est très très connu donc je vous
mets le côté noir un mat qui est très
connu donc pour ceux qui veulent
chercher je vais mettre pause à la
position à la vidéo pardon pour les
autres ben le match il est assez connu
vous voyez on va sacrifier la dame en
géant pour obliger la tour à venir
enfermer
son propre roi et ensuite après cavalier
F2 et ben c'est mat à l'étouffer donc
moi tu l'as assez connu mais je vous
rappelle regardez on a une dame c'est
important mais le roi 50 plus important
et là j'ai un mat en deux coups avec
Dame géant et cavalier F2
ensuite encore un autre exemple qui est
qui est très connu d'accord c'est le mat
de légal donc le match de légal ça
commence comme ça E4 E5 cavalier F3 D6
sans les pièces fuj G4 donc fougères
c'est un coup un peu limite mais on va
pas partir maintenant
cavaler C3
et H6 qui est une très très grosse faute
des Noirs ici les Blancs ont un coût à
deux points c'est le coup ici cavaliers
prend le 5 l'idée c'est que si jamais
les Noirs tout simplement mangent le
cavalier moi je mange le four grâce à la
découverte donc je gagnais un pion et en
plus la part de fou c'est encore autre
chose
mais ici oui enfin cavaler prendre 5 et
ben on a quand même le clouage du Fou
sur le cavalier qui a disparu et du coup
faut prendre dame qui est ici autorisé
par contre qu'est-ce qui se passe après
faut prendre des un quel était ici
l'idée des blancs pour mater donc pour
ceux qui veulent chercher je vous laisse
mettre pause à la vidéo et chercher le
mat qu'on fait les blancs donc le mat de
légal
faut prendre F7 échec seul coup recette
et maintenant cavalier 5 qui fait échec
et mat vous voyez le fou contre la case
du roi le cavalier contrôle celle-là le
fou entre les ici le cavalier en dessin
fait échec qui m'a fait la flèche et en
plus contrôle aussi la gaz F6 du roi
donc le roi en fait complètement cerclé
et la partie perdue c'est échec et mat
maintenant on va voir ensemble partie si
vous voulez la partie de enfin position
d'une partie de alekin alors ça c'est
une potion que j'aime beaucoup c'est une
miniature qui a eu lieu dans une
Française donc je vais pas en faire
appartement entier mais c'était une
Française et ici les blancs donc c'est à
l'équine champion du monde qui est blanc
et qui a fait mat en deux coups donc
pour ceux qui souhaiteraient chercher le
mat je vous laisse encore une fois
mettre pause à la vidéo et chercher les
maths donc bien sûr c'est des maths où
on sacrifie la dame parce que le thème
de la vidéo c'est le sacrifice de dame
donc ici vous avez le super coussin
échec vous voyez bien que le roi ne peut
pas partir en fuite à cause de mon super
fou en Aqua
soit on met la dame devant dans ce cas
là je mange et c'est mat en deux coups
soit on mange la dame et du coup
l'absence F ici fait que la diagonale
lance est ouverte et je peux ramener mon
fond en justice et dire échec et mat
prochain exemple là c'est une partie qui
a été joué à la Coupe du monde entre
deux Chinois donc Wailly avec les Blancs
et digne liren donc wave pendant la
partie il avait environ 16 ans si j'ai
pas de bêtises je crois qu'il avait 16
ans donc c'est une position qui est
tirée d'une e4-5 ou C4 dans cette
position les Noirs donc d'ingly Rennes a
joué ici cavalier H5 alors cavalier H5
qui paraît hyper logique vous voyez que
la dame attaque le cavalier blanc et la
seule pièce qui défonce cavaler c'est la
dame blanche du coup en Jean Cavalier H5
je viens chasser la dame qui défend
cavalier et ici on a l'impression à
première vue ben que les Noirs gagnent
une pièce parce que si je bouge madame
il y aura d'un pro cavalier et les Noirs
gagnent une pièce
ce qui se passe ici les blancs on fait
vous prend un F7 on a cette position
elle était connue par les deux joueurs
c'était un peu théorique mais
spectaculaire donc après la prise en F7
les noms enjeux roi A8 bien sûr tu
reprends F7 aurait pu être possible
aussi après d'un point F7 tu prends
cavaler prend on reprend un F7 ici ce
qui se passe c'est que les Noirs ont
deux pièces pour la tour mais les Blancs
ont quand même des pions d'accord donc
si vous comptez des pions les Noirs ont
5 pions alors que les blancs ils ont 7
pions donc j'aurai tout et de pions pour
deux pièces donc ces positions sont un
peu compliqué
en finale on préférera des fois la tour
et les deux pions c'est la moins de
pièces mais plus il y a de pièces va
chiquer plus cavalier four à l'avantage
contre la tour ça c'est encore une fois
une autre histoire François derrière une
vidéo là dessus un jour mais c'est pas
pour aujourd'hui
dans tous les cas ça vous prend un F7
les Noirs ont fait ici roi S8 et c'est
là que va apparaître le très très beau
sacrifice de dames parce que là encore
une fois après voilà je suis on se dit
mais ok madame elle est encore en prise
le cas il est encore en prise et en plus
il aime le fou aussi qui est en prise
donc là tout est en prise absolument
tout est reprise
chez
les Blancs et on a l'impression que la
position est complètement perdue pour
les blancs mais ici Wailly il avait tout
prévu et il a joué le magnifique
regardez bien le magnifique
dame G3 donc oui je bouge madame je
suis plus en prise sur F4 par contre je
suis en prise sur G3 donc doute quand
même ce qui se passe mais oui je vais
encore cavalier etc toutes les fondues
maintenant que se passe-t-il
sur Caval est proche parce qu'on a
l'impression que que il a fait un Mao
slip et qui peut atteint en avant qui
qu'il a fait une faute de souris et que
la dame est perdue alors qu'avec toi
c'est une très très grosse faute à deux
points d'interrogation très grosse gaffe
je vous laisse pour ceux qui veulent
chercher mettre pause à la vidéo et
chercher comment est-ce que les Blancs
ici peuvent faire
les autres je vous montre la solution et
qu'elle va les prendre j'ai trois du
coup tu es une très grosse faute avec
cavalier G6 qui fait échec et sur pion
congés 6 et ben j'ai ah je prends G3
échec et mat à la découverte joli ça bon
je peux mettre le fou devant la dame
devant mais je vais tout manger miam
miam et Fermat le fou contre la case de
futon G8 donc c'est c'est mat
donc sur dame j'ai trois d'ailleurs dans
la partie
d'échec d'un point F7 on a bougé
d'abandé 6 et la partie a continué donc
cette position elle est à peu près égale
d'ailleurs dans la partie ça fait nul et
voilà mais voyez la dame qui a été
sacrifiée en F4 puis en G3 fabuleux
sublime et pour terminer la vidéo je
vous mets une dernière position qui a
été déjà par le très sympathique Mathieu
cornette lors du championnats de France
en 2022 donc Mathieu Corvette avec les
Blancs qui a joué contre Sébastien FEDER
et dans cette position Sébastien fader
qui a joué la très grosse gaffe H6
attaquant le fou en G5 donc cette
position elle est perdue les noirs sont
mattes de partout je vous laisse
chercher et vous aimez écrire la
solution de l'exercice de la position
dans les commentaires de de la vidéo
donc pour ceux qui sont pas encore
abonnés à Youtube je vous invite à vite
le faire c'est gratuit ça nous soutient
c'est hyper cool donc n'oubliez pas de
vous abonner
à YouTube et aussi de marquer les
réponses sur les commentaires et merci
beaucoup et à très bientôt ciao ciao
[Musique]